all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are wrapping up
the thor story arc by donny case that's
correct thor
number six the devouring king uh
devourer king i think is actually what
it's what it's called
uh but what this does is a lot of you
guys probably know thor faced off
against the black winter
right and the black winter was basically
revealed to have been this being that
essentially gave galactus power
right that and that in effect galactus
was a herald of the
of the black winter and that galactus
had recruited thor in order to
help galactus bolster his power so he
could defeat the black winter
and it was essentially just a great big
huge ruse the reality of this was that
that galactus
was trying to escape his subservience
right he was trying to escape his role
as being the herald of the black winter
and then just kind of pawning it off on
thor as
the black winter wants to destroy
everything right so galactus more or
less lied
and when thor had realized that that
thor had basically started facing off
against the black winter and seemingly
galactus at the same time
right now what this does is it initially
opens up
after the conflict right and and what it
what it really shows us is the
appearance of the silver surfer right
the silver surfer shows up to thor
and basically says hey um look man like
this seems like it's been a pretty crazy
situation thor's like yeah
you know it's it's been pretty wild
right thor's drunk he's exhausted
right it was a hugely tiring set of
events right something that
has drained thor immensely but it's not
necessarily the conflict that drained
thor
it's what comes next that has made him
so tired right that is basically
revealed to him
the error of his wage the price to be
paid for destroying the black winter
when silver surfer asks uh ask thor what
did you see when you looked into the
black winner
thor initially shuts him down right he
turns him down and says no i'm i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna tell you i'm not
telling anybody what i saw
and the response to silver surfer is
actually really cool here his whole
stance is all right look man here's the
thing
if you keep this kind of thing to
yourself it's not gonna help anybody
right like i've been where you
are i've seen what you've seen it's not
going to help anyone here
so keep it to yourself if you feel like
you must but it's going to cause you
problems later on down the road
and so the result of this is that thor
ultimately ends up opening up
right and what we end up doing is
jumping back to the conflict at hand
right and really galactus responding to
the declaration of the black winter
that galactus is actually the herald of
the black winter himself right that
galactus
is owed to debt and ultimately or at
least the black winners oda dead you
know by galactus
and so ultimately you end up kind of
having thor who sort of
calls a bit of a ceasefire here right
and where the black winter is almost a
little bit distracted or sort of
going back into its normal form uh you
know galactus initially calls on thor
to say hey man like while the black
winter's distracted we should destroy
him and the response of
of thor is no you're not doing anything
right like you stay down because
what you've done is you've tricked me
you've lied to me you've helped me take
you to these different worlds
and destroy the denizens on them so you
could consume the world's energies
billions of people died in order you
know in order for you to maintain a lie
right and so in response to that
thor attacks galactus now one of the big
questions that i hear from a lot of fans
is they ask
if galactus gives a person a portion of
the power cosmic say for like
for for example silver surfer if
galactus gives the silver surfer a
portion of the power cosmic
and then galactus you know silver surfer
turns on galactus
why doesn't galactus just take that
portion of the power cosmic away
and we don't really know right we're
never really given an explanation as to
why that's the case why galactus doesn't
just
take that they take that portion of the
power cosmic and then just give it to
somebody else
we're never really given a definitive
explanation we can kind of assume
that the character is already there and
marvel wants to tell stories about them
so they just
keep their power cosmic so marvel can go
forward accordingly with the silver
surfer this is especially so because
nobody cares about nor rad
but everybody cares about when he's a
silver surfer right everybody cares
about those stories so it kind of makes
sense
but what donny cates does is take the
entire situation and flip it on its head
right
where normally we would expect galactus
to take a portion of the power cosmic
away from thor
that what thor actually does is in turn
take the power cosmic away from galactus
he literally absorbs it
and it makes sense right once you sit
down and think about it it actually
makes sense right
that the power cosmic is isn't really
it's not as though
you know galactus gives a portion of the
power cosmic to thor
with rules in place right there's no
real checks here it's not like you know
here's your portion of the power cosmic
and all you can do with this are these
few things this is donnie kate's hitting
on the old school silver surfer
because back in the day when silver
surfer first got the power cosmic
he could do things like time travel
there was no real limit to what it was
that he could do he had
all kinds of powers because the power
cosmic wasn't really well defined it was
basically just
this kind of source of power that was
out there that seemingly only galactus
could tap
into but what this means is that if
galactus can give the power cosmic to
somebody else
and donnie cates is hitting on the
old-school silver server silver silver
comics
then it means somebody else can take the
power cosmic away from galactus
it becomes a two-way street right that's
what galactus did he open this door
and thor is fully fully utilizing it
right and so he basically drains
the power cosmic off of galactus and and
literally says like for all the worlds
that you've killed
for all the innocent lives that have
died because of you i sentence you
to death and ultimately basically just
like attacks attacks galactus
and leaves them in this wildly weakened
state
this is kind of nuts right like this
really isn't something that we've seen
now
one of the big issues that i have with
this is not really with donnie cates
but the fact that this is something that
kind of goes as sort of uh
okay because in more recent years and i
don't like what marvel's been doing
in more recent years marvel's kind of
turned galactus into marvel's whipping
boy
right that's really what they've done
that in a lot of ways back in the day
back in like the the 80s
and and kind of in the 90s to a degree
that what you saw was galactus was like
this force of nature right when galactus
showed up
it meant things were about to pop off
and and even though you were only
reading a comic
it was still something that kind of
shook you a little bit like damn
galactus is here man like
dude this is a big deal but in more
recent years galactus i think is in a
lot of ways been so overexposed
and been defeated by so many characters
that he doesn't really maintain the kind
of
you know uh the kind of presence that he
used to right
this kind of intimidating aspect when he
shows up in the comics it's like
damn galactus now it's just kind of like
okay cool galactus and i think that's
kind of a problem but i think that's
kind of an issue
and so had marvel not done that in
recent years this would have been
a massive moment right it would be huge
and in a lot of ways it still
is but because of what's happened over
the years in marvel comics
a lot of us who are reading marvel are
kind of looking at this like oh god okay
so galactus gets destroyed by somebody
else now like
that's kind of how we that's kind of how
we see it and it's it's really sort of a
shame
right it's really sort of disappointing
to see galactus treated in such a way
right this is kind of
fearful intimidating universal thing
where like
races across the cosmos shaken their
boots at the very coming of galactus
right
the coming of galactus means the coming
of death but in in more recent years
it's like the coming of galactus means
like he's probably going to get
destroyed that's that's kind of what
what it means more recently in comics
but with thor basically defeating
galactus then ultimately what you end up
having is a galactus one
telling him you have no idea what you've
done right you have no idea
what you set in motion here and then two
the black winter actually thanks
galactus and says i appreciate what
you've done
i'm gonna take his body and then i'm
gonna head back and thor's response is
no you're not doing anything right
galactus basically stays here galactus
now serves me
right i will revitalize him or whatever
it is that i feel like doing with him
but galactus will now serve me and the
the the response to the black winter is
what's what could what could galactus
possibly do for you right like
i mean he's basically an emaciated you
know dead version of himself right like
galactus is not who galactus used to be
is he gonna serve you as like a slave
like what's the whole point here you
know and and the response of thor is
he's going to serve me as a bomb right
he's going to be used by me
as a bomb and what this leads to is it
leads to thor basically taking
the power cosmic within himself and the
power cosmic within galactus
and basically just setting it all off in
what is more or less a giant explosion
right
this huge explosion of energy which
totally obliterates
the black winter right destroys them all
the way down to like what is more or
less just a singular snowflake
and then it sort of speaks to thor for a
second before thor completely and
totally eradicates it
it speaks to thor and it asks the
question do you want to see how you die
right that's the one thing that we
haven't found out about thor yet from
the black winter right the black winner
shows you how you die
and it asks thor do you want to see how
you die
and thor says yes and and and before we
actually find out what that is
we switch back to asgard and we end up
finding out the helmet of galactus
is actually being used as a as kind of a
piece of the world tree
right it's almost kind of like a like a
a sort of trophy for thor right like
look what i did here right like i
single-handedly managed to destroy
galactus which is kind of a big deal
and it's a pretty cool little thing but
what it does is it basically has
thor have a conversation with nor rap
and thor's conversation here
is such that when nor rad you know kind
of continues his line of questioning and
says
what did you see it kind of picks up at
the the the moment right before
we switched over to the battle between
thor and uh between thor and galactus
that the the ending force saw that what
he saw was basically death
right he saw like he saw darkness now
the form his darkness takes
is thanos wielding the willing the
hammer of thor
that's also basically covered in the
infinity stones
so it looks like thanos finds some way
to take the infinity stones
and merge them with thor's hammer and
then what this looks like in the
background i'm not gonna lie
this looks like marvel zombies right
this is exactly what it looks like it
looks like marvel zombies
and it kind of makes sense if thanos is
obsessed with with death
then who better to lead the marvel
zombies than thanos and maybe that's the
reason why marvel zombies resurrection
have been postponed so much
is because once this this marvel
resurrection came or this zombie's
resurrection came out
and marvel was like hey like we've kind
of got a big hit like people want to see
marvel zombies come back then it was
like okay
let's make an event around it and i'll
be honest with you guys zombies have
kind of been a dead genre for like a
decade right
but it is cool to see like
thanos with an infinity gem lined thor's
hammer
leading an army of the dead right that
sounds
amazing and and seemingly thor realizes
this is all his fault but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you